that music is good for the mind body and
soul and our next guest they would
certainly agree they are performing the
musical theater production into the
woods starting april 27th in downtown
summerlin let's welcome to the show
director michael vajdo ditch am i saying
that correct oh no ah michael b
that's perfect michael b my man right
here you're directing this whole thing
and then we have the dance dynamics
troupe here as well we're so happy that
you guys are here why is music so
important to the mind body and soul um
it gives our kids and we have tons of
them from all over the valley um a way
to express themselves
non-verbally
through movement through dance and song
and we started this program about two
years ago to kind of help themselves
help them find themselves
and where so so you're students here
high school students and and anyone can
join the program yep
and tell anyone tell us more about the
production uh the production into the
woods based on the movie on the original
broadway show in the 1980s it takes a
bunch of different fairy tales
cinderella little red
baker and his wife
and it kind of puts its own twists on it
and things don't always turn out the
same as you remember them it's a free
show in downtown starland where is it
taking place in downtown ceremony right
on the lawn in downtown summerlin you
can bring a blanket chair food there's
food trucks there yeah it's kind of
festival style
so tell us tell us about the production
how do you guys like performing and
being out there in front of an audience
this is your first time on live
television how does it feel
oh my gosh it's so crazy i've i've been
doing theater since i was a little girl
so it's very near and dear to my heart
and i just love performing for people
and having such a crowd at downtown
samuel it's amazing and especially since
covid like we get to just have a huge
crowd and it's great
i've also done theater forever and
having such a big audience that we have
when we're out on the lawn it's just
it's just so amazing to see and to and
to have so do you ever get nervous when
you go out on stage to perform you walk
out on stage and you see the audience do
you ever get butterflies or once you're
out there you're performers you're
professionals you just go and forget
everything yeah a lot of the nerves are
like before but as soon as you're on
stage it's just like you're a whole
different person you get in the zone
right
you ever forget a line on stage um i
have
do you're not like me i i have a
teleprompter to read i got i've got i
got a fail safe let's talk more about
the actual show itself what time does it
start how many days a week there's
different start times so um
if you go online all our times are
listed there uh there's some days we do
three shows some days we do too but yeah
they're all there free for the public
this is a great family event too you
said bring the blankets bring some food
have a good time are you guys willing to
perform for us of course of course all
right this is going to be good into the
woods it's happening on the lawn at
downtown summerlin april 27 through may
1st free show take it away guys
you've changed
your thriving
there's something about the words
not just
surviving
you're blossoming in the woods
at all my fear
we'd stay the same forever
and then out here your passionate
charming
it takes one
to begin but then once you've begun
it takes two of you it's no fun
but what needs to be done you can do
when there's two of you if i dare it's
because i'm becoming aware
of us
as a pair of us each accepting a share
of what's there we've changed
we're strangers
i'm meeting you in the woods
who minds what dangers i know we'll get
past the woods
and wow
you guys will you remember us when you
win an oscar in the future
don't forget us little people thank you
so much into the woods having to get
downtown someone sorry to cut you guys
off but you're just stunning amazing
performance thank you so much